hello I'm Donna Friesen we're at that
time of the year that's usually so
exciting for kids school is out for the
summer
there are grad parties going on kids are
moving on to the next stage in their
lives this year all those milestones are
being marked virtually tonight we're
going to dig into the impact that's
having physically and psychologically
most kids haven't seen the inside of a
classroom in months have hardly seen
their friends and haven't played
organized sports screen time is up
activity is down a new study from
ParticipACTION gave Canadian kids a
d-plus on activity it found only 39
percent of kids aged 5 to 17 met federal
guidelines for physical activity the one
bright spot 77 percent of 5 to 19 year
olds participated in some kind of
organized sport or physical activity
both kids and parents want to get back
into the game John hua takes us through
the first tentative steps down that path
these sounds are music to every hockey
lovers ear
but at the local rink it's a whole new
reality it's different I'll have to come
fully dressed and not actually as taken
away from their locker room time with
the team but it hasn't seemed to phase
the kids at all I think they're just
happy about coming from designated
entrances and walkways to only a few
parents in the stands the Fraser Valley
Kings hockey program in Abbotsford
British Columbia has drawn up a whole
new play for the Cova 19 pandemic
obviously keeping the kids six feet
apart there's an element of the game
that you can't teach or work on right
now but there's a lot of the skills and
the basics you know as the kids get
through it's about the fundamentals the
spring tournaments have been cut
and playing games the focus now is on
player development we ever played a
month so I kind of forgot some things
they sure are beautiful there's a heavy
emphasis on the importance of social
distancing on the ice and with a limit
of one parent per player at the rink
this camera and a couple of clicks
online allow hockey moms or dads to
watch their child's progress from home
the family is they were loyal to me and
I promise to work really hard for them
to get them back in a rink and give them
a program that was different than
originally thought but you know as a
group they wanted to be here getting
back to activities like hockey could
have easily been benched until a later
date at all levels of government across
Canada have prioritized a return to play
because of the added benefit sport
brings during this pandemic it really
demonstrates the power of sport in terms
of providing physical and mental health
benefits but also that connection in the
community how it brings people together
the Fraser Valley Kings are following
the guidelines provided by via sport
Legacy Program of the 2010 Vancouver
Olympic Games and now the BC
government's liaison for organized
sports the guidelines do kind of get
handed down to the local club and it's
really after them to say okay how do we
implement this now with what we've got
and do we need to wait can we do this
now what do we need to adjust no matter
what the sport the key message is while
it might be good to be back and it's
going to look different than it was a
few months ago and it also may look
different from community to community
based on those guidelines BC hockey's
current phase includes social distancing
no non-essential travel and modified
play no league competitions you know
there's no training camps right now and
all of these things for now yeah it's
still fun ice I wish I was playing games
for associations like Ridge Meadows
minor hockey the future of this coming
fall is far from certain
speculation is the challenge right now
and we've worked really hard we we have
a number of different scenarios and and
plans in place the season will almost
certainly start with skills development
many are still holding on to hope for
the good old hockey game we'd love to
return to some form of game play if we
could it might start out a small area
game play you know and then maybe roll
into a three on three or four and four
format if we have to ideally though we
want to play five on five hockey and
that's the goal now spectators are a
major concern for every sport
organization because there are plenty of
parents siblings even grandparents who
want to watch their loved ones play in
British Columbia there's currently a ban
on any large gathering of fifty people
or more and that number can get even
smaller depending on the size of the
facility to avoid having too many people
in one place at one time so according to
via sport the key rule still applies
really sorry the key rule still applies
you have to stay at least two meters
away from anyone around you and a
reminder that's the minimum in Oakville
Ontario these young soccer stars are
finally about to score some time with
their team not exactly train with them
but still see them and to act at them
and that's I feel is gonna be a lot
better for all of us a return to the
pitch with a parent or friend is one
thing practicing with their club helps
these competitors push one another to be
better the intensity isn't the exact
same as you would being there with your
teammates well soccer Ontario unveiled
its restart plan in mid-june many clubs
are just trying to get off on the right
foot a recent survey showed 33 percent
of parents would return their kids to
the game 28 under strict conditions and
more than 12 percent would give a red
card to the rest of the year you've seen
that more in your recreational type
player whereas in your more competitive
player there's less caution because
they're willing to trust the system and
come back the drop in registration and
program fees has
led to an 80% drop in revenue and
reduction in staff the uncertainty has
Ontario soccer and many local clubs
worried from an economic recovery
standpoint we're looking at a minimum of
two years if not five years for parents
it's about juggling the need to be
cautious with Kovan 19 and knowing the
benefit the game brings when their kids
are together I'm more concerned about
his well-being mentally socially and so
you weigh that and I think we're in a
good place moving forward for these
phenom any kind of soccer will do the
trick
kicking it with their club will be that
much better baseball is considered to be
one of the safer sports to play during
this pandemic because it's outdoors and
mostly non-contact but the London
Badgers have just come back to practice
and not on the field all at once the
middle infielders are going right now on
the field the corner infielders are
hitting off in a different area the
outfielders are coming to stretch right
now baseball Ontario is limiting return
to play two regions and phase two of the
provinces restart plan with a limit of
ten players for in-person play the
Badgers are going for even smaller
training groups of five these are just
my like my best buddies and my favorite
like people in the world so I just get
to see them and hang out and play what I
love with that
and what happens when avoiding the
spread of covet 19 horses out the key
safety component of spotting from
competitive gymnastics that was
definitely for me the hardest thing
physical distancing means no one to
guide them through these gravity defying
acts my coach that I trusts and that has
spotted me for years I wasn't gonna have
her spotting me and even like after a
skill like when you do it and you feel
happy like I want to just like give her
a hug but like I can flip City
gymnastics in Langley BC part of
bouncing back from this pandemic means
getting back up and pushing forward
within your limits we wanted to make
sure that coaches work with their
athletes to ensure that they're staying
within the scope of their current
abilities and not learning new things
too quickly as they return gymnastics BC
has already struck a delicate balance
no more spotting but also other new
measures including 2 meter markers daily
screenings and enhanced cleaning
sanitizing high touch areas takes on a
whole new spin when it's basically
everything in sight I think that first
day I think we were all very nervous and
anxious on what the process would look
like but as soon as those kids started
coming through the doors it was it was
just exhilarating seeing any of these
athletes in action there's no doubt this
is a rough time for those on the cusp of
reaching the next level
they love to compete and we can't take
that away from them then that's what
they love to do so just be patient and
it will all come back but whether it's
on the high beam ball diamond soccer
pitch or ice return to play within this
new reality is a common goal across
Canada
this pandemic may have forced each
activity in every community to adapt and
change the way we compete trying hard
and doing the drills right and doing
them fast but the drive to come together
through sport is something not even
covet 19 can stop